john harbaugh here on the riches and
[ __ ] let me cross out that first
question is Lamar Jackson a quarterback
okay the coach here from the Baltimore
Ravens on the Rich Eisen show how are
you coach great to be with the rich
appreciate it man
so do you recognize the voice of that
man why I don't know who was that guy
yesterday no I got so so fired up out of
it I did I did the guy the guy that
asked the question - he's one of our
in-house guys so I write after that got
out his haircut low but he needs a
little work so but it was fun you know I
mean I mean you know hey this is you get
the same question all the time it's the
kid can throw okay he could throw well I
know I guess what folks are trying to
see is how how quickly you think he can
progress to being maybe a pass oriented
guy first maybe that might have been a
better way to to get it have that
subject well I mean you have to throw it
in this league there's no question about
it and he is that and the fact that like
it's getting asked so much I get it you
know and all that but but he can throw
we see him in practice every single day
he threw pretty darn well in Louisville
and you know and we've watched him
develop and we wouldn't have taken him
if we didn't think he was that guy so
you gotta throw we're not gonna run the
quarterback that many times down the
road it was a good start I think he
built from there and the way the kind of
the game was going it worked out for us
you know we were in pretty good shape
there for most of the time and the
running game was working so you kind of
keep going with it but I think we keep
building you try to put a rookie
quarterback in position to be successful
you know you wanted to be successful and
you want to win the game and do what you
have to do to win but I really have no
question no doubt whatsoever based on
seeing him every day in practice that
he's gonna be able to be a passer
oriented guy you have to be in this
league that's why we took him so it's a
good question and I'm confident you
gonna do well so my question for you is
as well because that that in terms of
making him successful you clearly you
clearly put more or had plays in the
PlayBook that you brought up that you
absolutely stayed in the obvious
wouldn't have with Joe Flacco under
center do you think that that it would
have looked as good as it did if you
didn't have a bye week before all right
that's a good question it probably helps
us we didn't really practice on the bye
week though rich we had one extra day on
Monday we have been practicing those
plays from the beginning and Jill
actually has run some of those plays in
games you know some of the rpoS and and
and even believe it or not we're too
Reed's Little Joe definitely wants to
give it more you know the mark keeps it
probably a little more often but we've
dabbled in that stuff and the Mars done
some of it games but you know when Lamar
was gonna take every snap you know and
the fact that was new and people hadn't
seen him before you know hey man take
advantage of it and let's roll but I do
think that you're gonna see more passing
out of us as a game come on
no with Lamar playing so how is Joe
right now oh he's good he's getting
better you know his hip is a
non-surgical deal it just needs a little
rest so I would say he's got an outside
chance for this week and then going
forward he's chances get better okay and
then how we noticed that Lamar did not
change out of his full uniform for his
postgame press conference is that
something that you're gonna try to coach
him up on as well uh yeah that's a good
point so you get the shoulder pads on
and everything didn't he it looks like
it to me yeah I think the kid wants to
play another quarter but I'm sure you
were happy to get out in regulation
though right right so where where do
things stand for your team right now
obviously five and five you got six
games left to go where do you like your
chances as you are currently the succeed
yeah I mean you know it's a great league
you know we would love to be a one loss
team or two loss team and all that and
we really could have been I mean we had
we've lost the close games we've won
some blowouts we you know we played some
pretty good teams we lost three you know
or we lost to the to some pretty younger
teams you know the Saints and the
Steelers are good and Carolina's had
some good games they played great
against us and that was our little
three-game losing streak you know close
games tough games and we lost them so
here we are tied with five teams for you
know sixth place I guess is what you'd
say and so I guess what that means to me
basically is you know if you've written
this off we're not out and if you've
gives you're counting this in we're
definitely not in we're right there it's
gonna be determined by what happens in
the next six games I like our guys
though rich I mean I would bet on the
Ravens you know I would if we were
allowed to but these kind of frowns on
that yes um Pete Rose you know I got a
baseball from Pete Rose man a signed
baseball for Pete Rose and he says I'm
sorry I bet on baseball it's crazy
are you serious yeah yeah side side ball
I love it from Pete
himself okay very good for those you
know we live in a fantasy football world
as I'm sure you saw on Monday night and
I'd like to ask you about that game in a
second can you tell folks where did Gus
Edwards come from who's this not out of
nowhere but I guess everybody seems to
think he did now he's he was a free
agent running free agent out of Rutgers
he's a he's a hard-working guy it's kind
of funny at the end of the game you know
it's hard to get Gus to smile
serious serious down-to-earth guy so
finally the guys we got the game ball
and the guys you know he we didn't ask
him for a speech but we did ask him for
a smile and gave us a smile so he's been
working hard man he's been looking good
in practice so it's just great to see
him have his coming-out party Ravens
head coach John Harbaugh here on the
Rich Eisen show as you know in the NFL
there's inside the building and then
there's the outside the building
conversation about goes inside the
building from what I saw during that
three-game losing streak coach to be
very honest with you I was surprised to
hear some conversation coming out of the
Mid Atlantic that you might be coaching
for your job would you agree with that
assessment well I mean I I think
everybody's coaching for the job
everybody's playing for the job that's
that's the nature of the National
Football League
so you coach I think you'd go to work
every day and the mindset basically is
not to keep a job is to do the job you
know and that's what that's what I've
been looking at for 11 years and for 34
years in coaching so I don't care about
any of that stuff I know it didn't come
from inside the building although the
quote unquote
the quote unquote source the NFL's
source whoever this NFL source guy is
he's got a lot of information but a lot
of it turns out not to be true so
hopefully that one turns out not to be
true too but I love it here I love the
players it's just been a blast coming to
work with these guys every day this is
such a fun team they work so hard they
buy in there's no drag they want to be
great and we're chasing that you know I
mean I think we have a chance to be a
great football team so they'll find her
way in the playoffs and roll and here we
do and it all starts with Oakland this
week so before we get again to other
matters maybe in the collegiate area I
want to ask you about that Monday Night
Football game and what you as somebody
who's been in this league for as long as
you have thought about the game and the
number of points scored and the style of
play and all of that coach yeah Wow I
mean Funspot I know we jumped out of me
with speed and what you originally
started thinking about his matchups we
had the
here we practiced against them for two
days here so we got we got you know it
was great for us to work against those
guys and all those talented guys in a
great offense at Coach McVeigh's running
of course I've been with Andy was with
Andy for ten years so you know it's fun
to watch it but really from a defensive
perspective and that's where I'm coming
from just trying to figure out okay now
how are we gonna try to stop that we do
play the Chiefs in a few weeks
mm-hmm are we gonna match up what kind
of coverage is how we gonna get pressure
you know those are the things you think
about so I mean I don't think that
there's gonna be 50 points scored in
every game in football because those
defensive players have a lot of pride
and they've got some talent so we just
hopefully we can find a way to slow him
down
well I mean it's interesting because
there's a conversation this morning
about the demise of defense in the NFL
and how this is a watershed game for
that perhaps in this day and age where
defensive rules are tilted towards the
offense or we're now in year 7 or 8 of a
collective bargaining agreement where
practice schedules where you can't put
guys in pads as much and there's not
much fundamentals being taught because
of that that this is the culmination of
all of that what would you say well I
don't know I mean I think there's some
truth to all that you know and
definitely defense has had big advantage
if you go back to like the 70s and 60s
the defenses did did hold all the cards
I mean heck linemen had to hold her
knuckles together right and block with
their elbows so a lot of these changes
have been great but I think the epitaph
being written way too soon on defense
you know one game does not you know
history make and will be you know
defensive coach is gonna figure out how
to stop people and all that and a lot of
it has to do with the way the rules are
interpreted through the way it's called
from year to year and you know there are
rules to protect the defenders from push
offs and things like that so you know I
think as long as we stay as long as we
stick with the rules as they're written
and they're officiated that way which
they will be and you know we'll be fine
there's a lot of talented guys you can
play defense I mean there are guys who
can cover these guys or guys who can
beat offensive linemen get to the
quarterback and sack the quarterback or
at least at least hurry him you know and
force the ball a little quicker you saw
that last night I mean that kind of
turned the game right so I'm not too
worried about defenses that's you know
it's it's week to week man it's a week
to weekly
that it's amazing and again I mean you
do have the number one defense in many
metrics going into the Thanksgiving week
and I don't want you to give too much
away obviously since you are taking on
Andy Reid and the Chiefs in just a few
weeks but Rod Woodson always told me
when you know when wild the Wildcat was
huge or when different offensive
wrinkles would happen that just give
defensive coordinators in offseason and
they're gonna they're gonna nail it down
what do you think with this style of
play could be the nail down on the
defensive side of the ball I don't think
you're doing anything that's like like
new to the game I mean it's all concepts
that have been run before and I think
they do a good job of attacking
coverages as they see them of getting
you in the right coverage and going
after him with certain routes I'm just
really executing really well with speed
so it's the combination of the
quarterback play the offensive line
giving them enough time and these
receivers running fast crisp routes so
the timing and the precision of the
passing game has been so good I mean the
Chiefs have a running back that's
breaking tackles left and right so again
to me rich it comes back to the players
I mean the great thing about the
National Football League it's a player's
league so coaches will keep up they'll
find ways to neutralize each other
schemes in the end you know the players
are gonna make the difference they're
gonna make the place and that's what the
fans want to see and really that's what
they saw last night they saw a great
precision great execution with a bunch
of really talented fast guys doing it
that's what made it fun okay last one
for you again I know you're the six seed
now intrigued Thanksgiving week you come
off a big win you got Lamar Jackson
there and Flacco hopefully for you
coming back soon if you if you need and
you know Raiders coming up but I forgive
me for asking how's your brother doing
how's he feeling right now he's pretty
pumped up rich I'm pretty fired up he's
a little nervous you know
I mean like the last as you as you know
cuz you follow it I mean you're like on
the edge of your seat every single week
with these guys right and you know I've
been following too I mean it's way
harder to watch Michigan football or
from my case Georgia basketball with Tom
and Joanie creams right than it is to
watch the Ravens I mean it is it is so
hard I mean you know you just stomping
around your living room right but but
they're they've been playing great and
the fact that they got through this
stretch and got Michigan State and got
Penn State and got Indiana
you know they got all these teams and
now they got the game that they've been
waiting for and
this is the one that matters so I mean
this is kind of this is it man this is
Michigan Iowa State 12 o'clock you know
it is I know isn't that great noon
Eastern they're not changing it for
anybody never that's never gonna be a
night game no that's the way Bo and
woody did it that's the way it's always
been done do you have got a good memory
of Jack your dad being on the staff a
bow on an Ohio State week he got a good
a good story here well we were always we
were we had these jobs on the sideline
we were spotters and they had a plugger
deal they had certain cords it had to be
plugged in and and then sometimes me in
the press box running hot dogs in the
media and all that you know and so we
always had jobs at the games and I can
remember standing right near Woody Hayes
right near him you know tearing up
sideline markers he's in a short sleeve
shirt and I can just remember how and it
was freezing cold it's Michigan you know
it's freezing cold
I remember how pink he was like his
whole body was pink you know he had to
be freezing but woody you do--if the
glasses he didn't flinch it's just it's
it's the 10-year war man it's it's
Michigan Ohio State you know I'm
half-tempted to guarantee victory for
him what do you think welcome I don't
know if your your your brother's gonna
like this but Quran higdon I don't know
if you're aware he guaranteed a win he
said nice happening I did see that let
me tell you something I got a feeling
Jim loves that what do you think I do -
that's what I said earlier in the show
here John is that this kid's gonna have
to run for a hundred yards speak it into
existence here we go it's a different
it's a different it's a different era
with the guarantee stuff
I believe it not playing yeah let's not
be scared not running scared here let's
go compete okay you guys so we're where
you gonna be what were you gonna be
tuned in I mean I know again you got a
game I mean will you be able to have
something on I mean what you're gonna be
no that's our break yeah we we practiced
until about 11:00 on Saturday and then
then we have some time to our night
beatings at 5:00 okay it's like the
perfect window okay and do you like
FaceTime in - who's having Thanksgiving
your dad or Jim next door who hosts the
Thanksgiving in an arboretum well I it's
a great question Sarah is a great cook
but I got a feeling my mom probably in
charge of that right next door I don't
know I mean we didn't get the invite
this year I probably know but you know
you like to get the invite at least I
know did I get a call I know by the way
we do a Thanksgiving morning show every
year now because we
were on the road for the horrible of
Thanksgiving with San Francisco at
Baltimore ninh went so well that we do
it every single year so I'll never
forget that that game and obviously the
year that that was so I always
appreciate you whenever we have a
conversation so thanks for calling in
coach appreciate rich thanks for having
me great being with you have a great you
have a great week much much to be
grateful for okay well I mean looking
forward obviously the Thanksgiving and
to see your game on Sunday but then
there's that there's that filet mignon
right in the middle that I'm hoping to
enjoy I'm sorry all right man Happy
Thanksgiving you too that's John
Harbaugh I'd coach the Baltimore Ravens
here on the Rich Eisen show the Rich
Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience